Lifeline is brought to you by
adamandeve.com who wants better sex and
who wants to start having better sex
immediately um hello everyone the best
way to get started is to go to
adamandeve.com right yeah because I'm
like how do you do it you know what I'm
saying and then you're just a good Adam
and eve.com okay that makes sense Adam
and Eve is offering 50 off just about
any item plus free shipping which
includes Rush processing more than that
Adam and Eve wants to make your life
easy they offer discrete shipping as
your privacy is a priority plus 100 free
shipping with Rush processing on your
entire order all right what if you buy
really expensive stuff and help me spend
so much money doesn't matter how much
you spend or what you buy all will be
packaged and sent discreetly for free
and fast whoa don't wait better sex is
just a click away so one item that's
fifty percent off one item one item free
shipping but not free rush for
processing with free Rush processes
bring more pleasure and satisfaction
into your bedroom just go to
adamandeve.com and select any one item
it could be an adventurous new toy or
anything anything anything
you desire just enter offer code
Lifeline at checkout that's Lifeline
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e at adamandeve.com this
is an exclusive off offer specific to
this podcast so if you're a homie to
this podcast be sure to use this code
Lifeline to get your discount 100 free
shipping and get it fast with Rush
processing code lifeline
but I have a business like uh I have uh
on myself I'm an owner right I have my
own business right okay and I'm doing my
own thing you know what I'm talking
about right yeah
no so I'm saying she was putting in work
in my company oh if somebody's putting
work in my company you know what's going
on many Illusions going on okay what I'm
saying is I was putting in work because
I have I'm self-employed okay okay so
I'm putting in work right now in my in
my own okay okay so you know what I'm
saying yeah okay and everybody at home
I'm sure you know what I'm saying if you
don't know what I'm saying I'm talking
about
rank
[Music]
hello hello hello hello
so is it all recording or what
is what we deal with every time it's all
good all right cool nobody ever lets us
know that they don't know we don't know
so we sit down and then it's just like
yeah we have to say are we rolling and
then nobody says anything and then we
have to say it louder that's right and
then only one of them says it but it's
too quiet so we gotta say what was that
and then they said and they both finally
say yeah we're rolling and it took too
long right I know and it's horrible it
took too long what we're doing
and then making sure that the answer is
yes and then telling you yes it takes
too long it takes so long yeah so here's
the deal though about the whole thing is
uh you are wearing orange and an orange
hat and an orange and I'm holding an
orange hat and I have a backup orange
and you I saw you throw this coaster
over here because it's orange right yeah
and then I saw you had a Coke but that
wasn't your lucky she got the large one
Perrier and that's um and you got that
because of the flavor because
this actually was not intentional but
it's a very happy accident yeah I had it
I bet it I have in my fridge I always
have l'orange lime and
bleep it out too early to set up and
plane and sometimes pink grapefruit but
not always
so boring what you just said so law
orange why is this one called why is
this one in French when the other one is
just grapefruit because this is lime and
orange Oh I thought it was not even
Perrier it's confusing yeah it is bad
marketing no it's actually good uh also
both of my orange beanies say the same
thing uh-huh God bless whoever hating on
me and let's just say this dude
it's episode 50.
yay
an elephant
are you
oh
um wow so annoying noise maker well
they're nois makers okay uh so it's it's
chrisley.com if you want to go get
tickets for the tour uh I will be in
um Minnesota Milwaukee Columbus
Cincinnati
Salt Lake City and other ones dude so
how great is that Boise I always forget
that one oh and uh I will be in Irvine
tomorrow that's sold out I will be in
Oxnard tomorrow the next night and then
uh it's Irvine Bray and Oxnard before I
go to Milwaukee uh Southern California
dates to practice the hour because
you're directing it um what nights are
those in Irvine Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Monday I think it's Monday uh
uh so that's that I think Irvine's
already sold out but and maybe they all
are yeah
tomorrow but not too warm right because
they stand up so
um yeah christy.com for that what about
matzulia.com oh I'll tell you about
matchday.com if you want private advice
sessions you go to mattdelia.com where
you will find advice time slots with me
Matt Delia who gives you private advice
that no one will ever know about
cool all right great well that's great
if you haven't oh dude what about the
hot new merch
look at that look at that
we got a lot of different we got a pimp
and purple ones right yeah grab put it
up on screen you can put up on screen
purple ones you got the other ones uh I
think they're up now purple is amazing
yeah you like the purple we got the
t-shirt that says advises here
you wanted he went you got the T-shirt
but he didn't want to get the purple
hoodie for some reason everyone is far
away but not that really but yeah we
love it
it's good it's very good it's better
hurry up and get that purple one though
because I'm gonna buy them all for
myself
hundreds of them but uh yeah so anyway
dude we're having a we're we're at we're
at uh just like And subscribe and that's
what's up you brought up an interesting
point uh in the bathroom actually what
did I say in the bathroom well first of
all you went um
and then the point you made was
um I don't like it either and I don't
think I've ever voiced it but when you
but I've definitely thought it when you
click the Switch for the light and the
fan goes on as well yes some bathrooms
only have one switch and if you turn the
lights on what goes on with it is the
fan that is too loud to completely
ineffectual even if it isn't too loud
never have the fan uh doesn't work
doesn't do anything I don't even know if
it's supposed to spit fan air out or
like suck it in yeah is it no no I don't
know because it's just a room it or you
know make it move it around rip it
around maybe around the room is what I
meant to say okay well either way it's
no one wants it no one likes it if you
want to have a fan that's totally fine
you gotta have a separate switch yeah
which is easy which is what I have in my
house
you want a light you turn the light on
and only the light I think that never
have the fan anyway we should just do
away with those those are like something
that they created in whenever whatever
year and then they know they didn't work
like immediately after and they still
have like these not only fans
grandfathered in from houses that were
built in the 40s but also they make them
now no you know why I have a fan of mine
I built it it's a new bathroom you know
why I have it why is because the AC it
does it doesn't reach that bathroom yeah
so the fan is actually for a reason
because it gets hot in there okay so it
gets hot in there so guess what fan
makes it not even cooler at all that
might be true because the reason why we
try around the reason I get it the fan
is in there to attempt to alleviate the
heat oh uh was that the dog oh that was
a dog yeah it sounded like somebody just
let loose okay out of their rear
and butthole
the worst author of all time the rear
and be descriptive and just saying the
same words the rear and butthole e n d
what no rear yeah end yeah yeah okay
rear end
butthole
okay you know okay so uh it's been so
it's been too much rain in Los Angeles
way too much that's great
congratulations dude hey rain how you
doing dude go away all right and the
thing about that is that when people
I know and everyone knows this too and I
don't know why if everyone knows it then
why does why do people still say it the
thing that everyone knows and people
still say is when someone brings up the
rain like you just did the rain sucks um
so over the rain and the other person in
the conversation says but we really
needed it oh oh are you a farmer are you
a farmer because if you're a farmer then
I get why you needed rain if you're a
guy in a loft yeah or if you're if
you're a woman in a house in in Studio
City yeah then you you didn't need it
yeah what does that mean Anyway by the
way because La gets caught up
immediately they don't even know how to
do with the excess rain they don't know
how to deal with it did they get the
rain and then there's no it's not
equipped to take on that rain it gets
filled up and then we don't we you know
it's just a flood people are crashing so
much I get flat tires that Los Angeles
most cities roads and highways were
built at a slight curve so that the rain
falls off on the sides in L.A and I
think probably other areas of California
as well the roads are just built flat as
if it never rains so that was built for
a city that never rains which nobody
ever thought that about Los Angeles mine
my Hill my I live on a hill right and it
just is a river just you can't even
leave
oh yeah I have a kayak to leave yeah a
guy here so um you park at the bottom of
the hill yeah yeah so my my shoulders
are awesome because I keep doing it with
the kayak but
um so but uh
they said so I looked yesterday and it
was like whoa this is the last time this
is like two a few months in the making
it's been raining but the last time
that the uh it's been months and then so
I looked yesterday and it says for the
foreseeable future there's no rain
and that's the first time in months it's
been like that and then today I checked
and it says next Wednesday it's gonna
rain
so they lied the applied here's the
thing most
most fields of study hey go away dog
yeah dog come on
so most fields of study get
better as as time goes on advancements
in the technology or whatever uh
predicting things like that get better
and better and better for whatever
reason
predicting the weather everybody sucks
at it as much as they've always sucked
in it when people were doing [__]
rain dances yeah because Dallas rains
could be on KTLA Channel 5 and be like
it's gonna be a stormy night tonight and
it just isn't at all I know and then the
next day guess who's on the [__] news
again being the weatherman Dallas range
and he gets it right never and he still
has a job that's true of everyone rub it
in her face his last name is Reigns so
he is just like that's like you know if
you're if you're if you're a street
walker and your name is Chris hooker
dude well that's a cool name
uh Dallas rains though is the coolest
name yeah but only always get it right
when it rains but they can't because
this is what they do they go like this
first of all he's a weatherman he
doesn't even he's not the guy that's
like no I think you are gonna rain I
used to have a degree really don't tell
me all those chicks on the Telemundo
with the bubble butts that are just like
it's going to rain well I don't know
they went to school but you're supposed
to have a meteorology background if
you're gonna build a [__] weather
person so that's why he changed his name
but here's the deal dude uh this is what
it is this is what they do they go like
this
Thursday it's going to be cloudy yeah
half the time they do that yeah they
don't they're not nobody just look at
another Channel I know an original
Source right that is wrong and everybody
is is like copying the person that is
most recently looked at that thing yeah
yeah so anyway dude it's got to change
really really we had to talk about the
hard dating issues but it's got to
change yeah
um things got to change around here
anyway whatever dude
oh what what you know yeah
this is a good podcast man and it's like
I want it to be the number one podcast
and it is in many ways what everyone
wants for their podcast yeah but uh but
they don't really get it and this is it
dude this is where it's at it's been
good lately I gotta say I never I never
listen to it or watch it but I listened
to last week's and it was it was good it
was a good good good good thing the
worst author
good good good good hey good good good
good
good good good good good good
so um all right well let's get into it
dude you know what I mean real quick
before we do okay okay I got something
to say about the people who make
appointments with me oh okay
if you don't have something to ask
advice about so what's up don't
waste my [__] time yeah but
aren't they paying for it they're paying
for it so who cares but no it still
makes me mad though because
like I don't want to say the thing of
what it was okay but it's happened
enough now okay that it just it's like
if you want to try to contact me like
reach out to me in a way that is how
people reach out to people like find my
email people have done that in the past
uh I'm on Instagram DM me you know but
like you're gonna make an appointment to
like I don't do that and it makes me
feel bad the rest of the day and I don't
like it well all right okay okay I don't
know what it is but okay
I bet you could guess
yeah probably yeah I bet you could yeah
because they yeah they live in uh
somewhere else and they wanna
make it
no oh okay yeah no clue so um
uh
yeah let's do it
what's up Matt and Chris my name is Kate
I'm from Newcastle Australia Chris my
boyfriend and I we met you in they're
awesome last year the whole reason to
America and it truly was wow thank you
so much thank you Matt we love you too
of course of course
um I'm a big fan I always watch the
podcast and before we come to America I
was really curious about this drink
that's always on the table with you guys
it's this green can I've got in my head
it's this delicious refreshment
something citrusy maybe like Sprite
and when we come to America I made it my
mission to find it we don't have it here
in Australia
we found it somewhere finally in an
airport and I grabbed my boyfriend and I
was like quick we could have gone by
this drink I I need to try it and I'm
reading the label and
guys
it's soda water yeah
I'm not really sure if I'm asking for
advice maybe I'm asking for you guys to
look within maybe I'm asking for some
clarity but if that really is spicy
water the taste like TV static I think
we all need some answers okay it tastes
like what TV static what she said she
thirsty are you on acid because you want
a delicious drink
drink Sprite yeah that's your options
yeah spread it the thing about Sprite is
that it [__] rots your insides like
this drink yeah but this drink is water
so water is always better to drink than
any other thing because water and also
my uh sun-like Sprite and it's because
it ruts or insides because they can
trick a three-year-old but they can't
trick this dude I'm 42 and I know that's
young but uh they can't trick me so I
drink now do I want to drink Coca-Cola
all day do you really all day when I
stopped drinking Coke for a long time I
I have a I have one after a long period
I don't like it and I don't it I don't
understand why I end up coming back to
it but I do maybe you have to look
within wow but I'm also no Perrier it
also is [__] good yeah but you have
to you have to I didn't like it until I
stopped I drank soda I drank Coke every
single day multiple times a day then I
was like oh this is disgusting because
you're I'm destroying my
Diet Coke is great Diet Coke is terrible
Diet Coke and it tastes like chemicals
and then it was like well you're still
destroying your body because of
chemicals so then I was like all right
dude I guess I can try to drink this
club club soda again and I tried and I
was like it's not so bad it's the
carbonation I was addicted to now you
know I'm a raging addict I'm a hardcore
addict and uh I drink uh you know that's
why I love I want to drink Coke every
day and I don't drink Coke every day but
I don't want to do it so what was the
point of anything that you just said uh
it's it's good and it's an aquarium it's
good it's an acquired taste though my
point is you don't just like it from
jump give it some time also she drinks
other stuff still Sprite if you drink
Sprite and Coke and all this stuff
you're not really Gonna Love Perrier to
its fullest extent no it's like it's
like you're not gonna like uh CBD if
you're doing heroin all day exactly yeah
exactly so get off get off my back yeah
all the way from Newcastle get off my
back number one that's step number one
yeah number two give it another try yeah
have two maybe not just one Sip and say
ew and then take your Sprite back yeah
like a little kid also we didn't claim
it to be anything yeah no I didn't say
we'll just see you're busy you know
chilling just drinking our [__] and she
comes in all hot by the way she and her
boyfriend are awesome I met them in
Denver and I remember that they were
trying to go to a show and they were and
they they came to America to actually
see me which was awesome and they made a
whole trip out of it but they're both
really really cool I like them a lot
Okay so
anyway sponsor me Perrier and that's all
I have to say about that okay that would
be the weirdest sponsorship no it would
be the most obvious they need it because
I'm always you're fresh holding it to
the point that people in New Castle even
know that that's true you know people in
Newcastle seeking out the dreams because
it's always on the table I got some back
here yeah and uh that was a naughty
thing to do to call him about that yeah
and she said and it's out of water and
she said it tastes like saving static
yeah and you said what I said TV static
because dude I know it I know what
people mean when they say it yeah well
all right next one
guys I'm KB calling from St Louis
Missouri I'm an original baby and Matt
I'm a really big fan I love it thank you
first of all I want to thank you guys
you've gotten me through some really
really dark days last couple of years
finally reaching a clearing but there
were some days where I thought it was
just done being a joyful Life For Me on
those days you brought belly laughs back
to my belly and big smiles back to my
face so thank you for doing what you do
my questions about this really amazing
guy that I'm seeing when I start to talk
about it my face starts to cramp because
I smile so much he's my best friend
already it's been two and a half months
because everything I've ever prayed for
um
he stinks like [__] what do I do but
everything's perfect our chemistry's
stronger friendships strong everything
is wonderful here we go last night I was
putting in the work
and
he seemed to be really into it so I
looked up to see his face he was on his
phone oh when I asked him what he was
doing it was Twitter porn obviously he's
really into me but was I doing something
wrong help
was she doing something was she doing
something wrong what what did she think
she he was looking at porn on Twitter
right that's what Twitter porn is right
yeah
um what what's going on here
I just can't believe that well can't
believe what did I miss something she's
going to town on the day oh oh oh she
was given the dang it down oh I didn't
know she was doing that she said work I
thought she was busy doing like her no
she was given uh Mr monkeys close up
right well why was she looking at his
phone when
I don't say Mr winky right but why why
why was why was why was he looking at
his phone dude you achieved the thing
because
I mean it's like the guy but last week
he was like he he couldn't have sex with
his girlfriend
oh man
this is this is not as bad as the other
guy this is not as bad as the other guys
okay yeah the other guy was worse yeah
uh but I I mean I wish I knew it was was
he like oh like fumble in this phone
like pretending it was something else
because he should have been
it's weird it's so bold dude yeah to
just be like
I'm bored
yeah but what do you do what do you
[__] Alexis Texas or whatever you
know
is that that one is that is that a porn
star for real I think so yeah yeah that
that's the one with the really really
big butt right yeah yeah
um acting like he doesn't know me me I'm
the one who said who it is I do know I
mean I was joking first of all [__]
relax on me dude no I know who she is I
mean I thought well here's what you said
Alexis Texas I thought wait a minute is
that a real porn star is that just from
the the song
Alexis Texas
is it real that's why I was asking and
then once I knew it was a real one I
knew who it was Alexa dude you're not
gonna get me you're getting real loud
and you're Crossing the the invisible
barrier and you're pointing getting too
close to me okay so yeah he was watching
Alexis Texas while he was getting domed
yeah I mean what do you I mean I don't
oh that's not good right ah it's weird
it's a boss move but not a real it's a
guy who think he thinks it's a boss move
maybe but it's not actually a bus move
no it's an it's an inconsiderate move
really real real inconsiderate I I don't
uh guys that do that I mean I'm assuming
there's not that many but if you do like
have you ever heard of like using your
imagination dude it close your eyes and
think of a thing yeah
if you're people are hooked on their
phones I do that sometimes when I'm like
if I'm you know doing my thing if I'm
solo you know what I mean if I'm just me
just kind of like working it do put it
in work right if I'm putting in work in
my own work right if I'm in my I have a
self business like I have a business
like uh I have uh on my cell phone my
owner right I have my own business right
okay and I'm doing my own thing you know
what I'm talking about right yeah
no so I'm saying she was putting in work
in my company oh if somebody's putting
work in my company you know what's going
on many Illusions going on okay what I'm
saying is I was putting in work because
I have I'm self-employed okay okay so
I'm putting in work right now in my in
my own so okay okay so you know what I'm
saying yeah okay and everybody at home
I'm sure you know what I'm saying if you
don't know what I'm saying I'm talking
about
masturbation and don't break we can
bleep it out but we know right right so
now that you've said it 17 times if I
was doing that though I I sometimes look
at the phone and look at
p-o-r-n okay just to p-o-o-r-n porn
Indian dish and so uh what I do is uh
sometimes I go you know what and I just
and I mean myself and I'm self-employed
but um you know what I mean I'm doing it
myself no I'm not asleep I'm just
imaginating okay
so uh but you're not and I'm
self-employed getting you're not in the
middle of a sex act with your intimate
partner yeah no I know but I'm saying
that and everyone does those things when
they're alone but I'm saying that you
have to you have to hook into the Matrix
and actually be there and thinking of
really good stuff and be like oh God
okay okay because sometimes you'll just
be like nah I'll grab my phone and then
you're addicted to the phone and then
you're addicted to you know what I mean
okay and that's what that guy could be
doing because that's where you get the
most dopamine hits two and a half months
you're already looking at your phone
while you're getting domed out when Mr
Winky's getting his close-up I don't
like when you say just like
you're already reverting to that that's
not
I believe her that everything's great
it's a good relationship but like you
gotta confront them about that yeah well
you can't be like what did I do wrong
yeah nothing no no no yeah you did
nothing wrong yeah the guy obviously has
to some degree
I'm not trying to diagnose them but to
some degree he has some kind of problem
yeah also why Twitter Hey guys there's
way better thing dude what you're
getting hung up on the Twitter thing
dude you're on Twitter looking at porn
dude that's so weird there's so much
porn on Twitter yeah I know but you know
where there's even more porn porn sites
go to a porn site dude the guy's just
like the guy was just like checking what
Elon Musk was saying he was like you
know what maybe he's Alexis Texas maybe
he's got like tabs or people he follows
he can just eat on Twitter or in one
place yeah yeah I want to know what his
reaction was when she looked up
because if he was just like
what's up
I'm just checking yeah oh yeah on the
thing I'm just checking my email huh
like this one oh yeah uh I got emailed
from work
I mean she sounds really all over into
this guy but I don't know yeah oh yeah
just checking email from work oh man
both of you
oh yeah not a work email [__] yeah
dude that was funny
um
so yeah it's it's kind of weird I mean
maybe that also maybe that's his Kink
maybe he's like yeah I like being
distracted but she he should say that no
all of course of course of course so I
feel like uh bring it up for sure bring
it up oh also if it makes you feel
insecure which of course it does that's
yeah that's uh that's an interesting one
but yeah just ask him about it too like
oh what's up with that Twitter also
White twitter get definitely say why
Twitter and I am hung up on the Twitter
thing but definitely say why Twitter
though why didn't you just go to RedTube
I don't think she cares is the points
why Twitter what's up why why
yeah ask him see what's up I'm not
trying to ruin your great new
relationship but it sounds like he might
be so
ask him you got to confirm about it no
matter how uncomfortable it is you
didn't do anything wrong he did so he
should be the one talking about it yeah
not you yeah
all right next one
what's up guys love your podcast thank
you I've done this like 10 times so I'm
just gonna record it real quick and
send it in over the back you're doing
really well so far yeah me and my
boyfriend are moving from Baltimore to
Los Angeles in July
here okay and my problem is that I'm a
freelance photographer and I work with a
few small Brands here and I just need
opinions honestly on when to tell them
like no one really knows it we're moving
so I can't really ask anyone around me
what they think
um because we're kind of just like
piecing out okay and I don't want it to
like get around and get to those yeah
the the owners of these businesses right
so I don't know like I've heard someone
like my boyfriend said like four months
in advance my mom said two weeks in
advance I was like I can't do that to a
small business like I run their whole
language like I do their photos
Instagram yeah website all the things
so I don't know I guess I just need
opinions I was thinking like a month in
advance
um I don't know I'm really nervous I'm
an empath and I don't want to like screw
them over me too dude I'm really excited
that I'm helping her and she just
recently opened up like
her like one-man show to like let other
people help and I just don't want to
like screw her over so that's nice yeah
I mean I just need opinions from people
I don't know
you gotta stop thinking that you're
screwing anybody over yeah people live
their lives and people other people
understand that but I think that um
four months is ludicrous well that's a
long time yeah two weeks is normal but
for I understand why your situation yeah
it's kind of too close yeah to the
actual date not giving them enough time
to find someone new but I would actually
even up to four months out or however I
don't know how much time you have before
you move but there should you can even
like feel it out and be like me my
boyfriend are thinking about leaving how
much time would you need
if we were to go like right to not to
not be [__] over way way good you know
or if you just need a date that you want
to just say and then be done with it I
guess a month a month seems that seems
fair yeah and then also maybe it's a
thing you can like do and uh say yo uh
I'm I'm gonna peace out in a month but
then also set up some sort of way even
when you're gone you can help them
you're going to suggest that [__] yeah
I'm helpful dude
so uh I got this shirt on from Roe
r-o-u-h it's really good actually they
sent me some stuff I really like this
shirt huh you know who sent me some
stuff yeah the guys that God bless
whoever hating on me shout out to ro for
sending me these shirts shout out to God
bless whoever hey well I'm trying to do
my thing but you know
um why do you have two orange ones by
the way they sent me stuff so why do
they have two on you oh cause I wanted
to be able to mix it up you're barely
mixing it up I put both on at least once
so far this episode
this one looked better on you you think
this one why
it's darker it goes with your vampire
complexion better I look I look I have a
bad I'm a bad color huh but I don't care
no you're not a bad dog that's better
though yeah for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm a homie
so uh such a dad so um
so yeah so uh yeah I say a month or
something like that a month is good yeah
okay I'm gonna be leaving why'd you put
yours on because I put mine on yeah all
right I don't know why dude I [__]
shut up I know I know you don't like it
but you gotta give credits do don't you
wow Jeff Bezos dude the thing the thing
about it is
oh [__] dude
what you sucked no way like straight up
your a bodybuilder a bodybuilder
four times you raise your arms you suck
even more dude that's crazy a body
stripping dude how dumb is bodybuilding
like uh I don't know let me rewind is it
okay
bodybuilding is not dumb
at all I think bodybuilding is great
okay I think it's cool to have
competitions and but man imagine that
your life dude isn't that crazy I think
if you're a bodybuilder and you you get
to the point where you're so big and
you're looking at and you're like I
really need to work on this one area
right here and it's like a 10 by 10 inch
section and you're just at the gym
trying to work that one area I I think
that you
have to if you're so focused on the male
physique you have to start
[__] guys oh I didn't know that's
where you were going I think that it has
to be done usually and I don't even mean
in a gay way I just think they got to be
like like a dominance I gotta [__] guys
but but most of them I would imagine are
driven by more like an over a higher
amount of testosterone than other men
okay so I would have I would that leads
me to believe that that would be the
opposite of true
bodybuilders are like less of that
population is probably almost but isn't
it also the same though being super not
gay is gay sure I mean it's just like
anything else the far ends they all
reach each other you know and this is
basically NPR so we know but right yeah
we have studies right at our fingertips
so do I look so I look pretty [__]
chill and chilling right you look all
right but don't get the hair coming out
like you're an extra in [__] Boston
public
oh my God that's horrible that's bad hey
what's up teach make it stop make it
stop skateboarding
dude Hollywood [__] up not using me
for stuff I mean my [__] is fantastic
for real what what I'm just a funny good
actor dude okay okay yeah
sounds good sounds good man uh imagine
me in a movie just being super funny
okay I'm that funny
all right all right all right who's next
who do we got all right
so close
hey Matt I've been a big fan uh hey I'll
get right to the point my wife can never
decide where she wants to eat that's
breakfast lunch dinner uh I'll ask hey
what are you in the mood for she'll say
I don't know you pick and then I will
make a million suggestions she'll turn
down every single one but she won't ever
make a suggestion
um to the point where we're both
starving we're both angry at each other
that we haven't eaten
um so but most of the time I'll just
think of something and I'll go out and
grab it yeah hopefully she'll eat it
good uh but any advice that I can get
from you guys to encourage her to make a
decision
um any way I can approach it so that she
can make the decision on her own because
I'm sick of this appreciate it guys no I
dude congratulations you're married to
Every Woman yeah you're you're in a
relationship with a woman unreal dude
what's what you're doing so it'll be
best for you to just accept it because
it's Never Gonna Change go pick up the
food bring it home that's dinner yeah
you don't ask because it's just like you
do ask yeah but because you're a nice
person you're not just like get the
dinner and drop it on the table and say
that's what's for dinner hey
like rude I mean you're just throwing it
at her but but they a woman or or a man
for that matter isn't gonna like that
they're like didn't you want to ask me
what I wanted you gotta ask some women
you gotta ask and then accept the fact
that they're not gonna have an idea then
you can put forth your idea so just
better think about it this way it's
better for you anyway you get the
[__] pick
such a waste of time okay you don't
really get to pick what do you mean
don't dude dude Kristen and I do this
all the time what do you wanna I say
what do you want to order she says I you
know I don't really care you can get
whatever get whatever Sushi I can't
because okay you want to get the uh the
place Trattoria Del Sol I love that
place you got that last time okay
um dialogue well I'm not in the mood for
breakfast food okay so and here we are
dude and it's like okay well then you
make a suggestion and then it's this for
an hour and a half
like looking at Yelp and [__]
or Postmates or one yeah and it's like
and she's like let's get and then she'll
just be like let's get you know
Fry's Electronics and I'm like this is
not even they don't even have food like
it's just so far off gonna get a
PlayStation eating wires
eating that UFO that's [__] crashed
into the Burbank one wow I totally know
that yeah wow that's so technical
uh okay so I have that when I build my
new house I'm gonna have that on my
house so the the advice for you is yeah
realize that you are a heterosexual man
on Earth and good advice and deal with
it that's it
you're married to every every woman dude
I'm Every Woman I don't know what I want
what I want wow
suggestions and I don't want them ooh
Rue you asked me what I want Rue Rue and
then I don't and then I keep on
scrolling oh yeah
screaming just absolutely screaming at
the top of your room I don't want sushi
bro who's Rue
dialogue Rue just pick me up some
McDonald's even though
cancer
dude my wife is like no I don't want
that she'll go to a whole nother app
she'll like start using doordash like
who even uses that what sometimes I do
though because it doesn't has Cheesecake
Factory yeah what's your problem with
doordash dude you've had a long running
problem on this podcast talking [__]
about doordash it's fine well I actually
it's the same actually just different
places
it's the same they're just people who
pick up food and bring it to you I use
it oh okay then shut the [__] up about
it I'm making jokes oh okay well now you
got real about it I use it with the I
get the the Miso salmon oh dude if you
don't get the Miso salmon from
Cheesecake Factory you ain't nothing man
for real wow okay it's so good but I
don't like it when they deliver it
because they don't give you enough
[__] miso man
so what do you do when they bring to you
in the restaurant they give me enough
miso oh oh but we don't have to ask for
more miso no it's all good so what
happens so then when they deliver it
they put it in the little cups that they
have they don't want it to get soggy no
no well that's fine but put give me
another cup of miso do it or just have a
bigger cup when they don't bring enough
I'll tell you what me so angry wow dude
okay
all right what's up what's up next huh
huh
she called in already yeah we know very
quick my name is Amara I'm a huge fan I
said that yeah
two days after I sent the video in where
you know he said I was ugly as [__] yeah
I might as well apologize oh two days
after I sent it in not after you guys
put it out there he randomly brought it
up the other day when I said I don't
know why I [__] said that I'm so
sorry I love you you're so hot blah blah
blah oh yeah so I just wanted to give an
update that he's not he's not a terrible
person he realized I don't know if he
said that because he has some sort of
insecurity where if he thinks if he says
that too yeah it's gonna mean something
I don't know I just wanted to let you
guys know he apologized
cool and thank you guys for your input
it was really cool love you both
awesome you're the [__] you know what's
interesting is um Cut Her Off by mistake
so rude so you know what's interesting
is uh
Chris Christmas
dude I think that um
it's it it actually like to think about
I you know I grew up in La kind of you
know I know we're from dirty dirty
jurors but like we we and I'm I was 12
right and yeah I've got my jersey roots
in me you know what I mean the over 12
so I was nine eight or nine wow okay
yeah and yeah you know I got my East
Coast Road to me like my heart bleeds
for New York and all that [__] but it's
just like you know my soul is at home
the [__] up okay all right now go
anywhere closer to New Jersey my soul is
at home but
um you know in La I kind of was you know
East Coast born west coast raise that's
what I like to say so me and Tupac have
a lot in common so I feel like I just
keep wondering if your story's gonna
start no but the streets from um
Baltimore and then and then he went to
do a lot of stuff in uh Oakland who
Tupac okay who gives this [__]
who the [__] [__] tell your story
okay so we have a lot of comments so her
uh it so I you know in La it's a
different it's a different ball game hi
how you doing I'm a different ball game
welcome to LA right when you get there
all right
um you grow up you're raised in L.A the
the chicks in LA
they're not used to this oh let me get
the door for you they're not used to
this WOW don't you look ravishing
they're not used to that stuff ravishing
no one in the 21st century is used to
that but I'm making a point right I
guess the point is what they don't do is
there's not a lot of complim in La
should it if you see you could see the
illest [__] not even talking about women
you can see the illest [__] on the west
coast the way to respond to the illest
[__] is like this that's cool
that sucks though it does suck yeah okay
yeah we're in agreement yeah uh on the
East Coast people are more likely like
wow this is amazing this is that that
right but on this relaxed kind of so I
grew up in La raised right like Tupac
like in the in the west and so
uh
the the women in LA are used to this
Vibe of yo we want the dudes that don't
give a [__] right so you it's it's it's
more attractive to a lot of these women
to not open their door don't agree with
that now let me tell you why though okay
let me tell you you figure out too close
to my phone okay but let me tell you why
though because
then they're like why didn't he do that
for me he doesn't like me and that leads
to I need to make sure this guy likes me
and now you're the one being chased but
that's not the same thing as her
leggings yeah I figured it out that's
not the same as that's not the same as
her liking it more that's the same as
manipulating someone into liking you for
a [__] false reason it's not the same
thing at all I used to do that
opening a door for someone is [__]
just polite you're right and I think
that that is what you should do you
should do that however there's this
[__] wavelength and vibe that you're
going to get more chicks if you do it
that way and that's something that's not
far into a lot of dudes and what I'm
saying is when you're in that culture
and you grow up in that culture it's
hard to look at somebody and say you
look very beautiful
because that's not how you grow up
so I'm saying if maybe this guy is like
that I don't know but it's hard for a
lot of men to look at women and be like
you know you're your woman their own
long-term partner it's hard for them to
look at them and say hey you're really
pretty yes and I'm saying yes yes yes
it's an insecurity the lowest bar ever
you know I mean I'm saying though that's
how it is like I look at my wife I do
that and I've done that my life with
with women but like it every now and
then I'm I I I think about that and that
is true you grow up you know and I grew
up in the dirty dirty streets of Jersey
right yeah and then I moved out here to
L.A and it's bang bang city right yeah
but yeah I don't keep my thing on me
yeah I've got a [__] trunk of Barry
manilows but I don't use it okay what's
that
um I heard it in a rap song I think it's
guns oh
you don't even know what it is that you
have in your own trunk
I don't have guns in my trunk okay okay
um yeah so so but real quick what you're
saying is that guy
[Music]
has a hard time saying his girlfriend is
pretty Maybe
it's not necessary that he has a hard
time saying his girlfriend is pretty he
has been he could have been grown up in
the culture to where it's like yeah
don't admit your feelings be cool be the
one who's chased like this is all stuff
that I identify with and like I had to
fight all right loser I'm not a loser
anymore I was a loser loser
I just I'm just trying to look at all of
the things that's what I do okay well
I'm looking at the thing that it's super
[__] easy to tell your girlfriend
that she's pretty
even honestly even if you don't think so
right then it's still really easy he
obviously thinks his girlfriend's pretty
well obviously he said so as himself so
he did good he was two days later he's
like damn I was a [__] dick why did I
say that he did so because wow
love wins okay love wins guys they say
that a lot for gays but I I think
everyone for everyone love wins even for
heterosexuals is that associated with
like love wins is a gay thing it is yep
it's like well we love you can't not let
us marry we love each other even though
it was gonna have a penis you can't stop
us right okay it's a gay thing but I
don't think it's a gay thing I think
it's a universal thing heterosexual gays
and all the other ones well okay well
okay next one good for you yeah
I came and saw you in Lakeland Florida I
was one of two black people at that show
that he loved was the other one
um my question is about work so
naturally I'm I'm two minds about
everything on the one hand I think I
should be grinding 26 years old I don't
have a hard job I'm working almost every
day
um but I'm also of the mindset of like
you know I should be enjoying my youth I
should be having more days off I should
be going traveling stuff like that
um so I don't really know I'm single I
don't you know have any uh major
commitments right now that I have to be
off of work but taking days off just for
me or raise what's up with that so let
me know Pimpin life ripping
yeah dude hell yeah dude I think you're
still young obviously I think that
when you're young and single there's
like the societal pressure to be like
you got to get it out of your system you
got to do this you got to do that squirt
everywhere but here's the thing that's
only true if you want to do those yups
other people saying that it's a what
you're supposed to do is not a
sufficient reason for you to do it yeah
if you want to travel and be single and
just try to meet women around the
[__] world whatever
then do that because you're right you
can you're not tied down to anything you
can get days off from work uh but if you
don't want to if you just want to Stack
paper and chill until you meet someone
you really love in your area or whatever
then do that don't at all subscribe to
someone else's especially like some
nameless vague group of people's idea of
what one should do at your stage yeah
what you're saying Q Anon
always says that you need to go live
your Youth and not and and go around the
world in trouble yeah
um no I I found one of our core tenants
yeah
um
yeah stop yeah stop child trafficking
also
go travel a lot so sell your Wild Oats
um I feel like uh
yeah dude I I
I this stuff actually never made sense
to me if you want to do travel go travel
if you want to work hard he said he
doesn't his job's not hard what do you
want in life do you want to be on the
path of where you are do you want to be
in the profession you're working in if
you do
do you want to be successful do you have
a goal do you know what you want do that
if you don't necessarily know what you
want yet maybe travel and live your
youth a little bit you know yeah yeah it
my sense is that he he does like his job
he's just he's saying it's easy he
didn't say my job sucks or anything yeah
yeah no I didn't say that
um
but yeah I don't know I I get what
you're saying being of two minds when
you're at a certain part stage in your
life when people tend to think that
you're supposed to act this way or that
way right but honestly all that getting
older has afforded me is the knowledge
that that is just [__] [__] and
the more I remember anytime I think of a
time in my life where I listened to like
the sort of like vague majority idea of
what I was supposed to do at a certain
time or a situation yeah those are the
only situations I regret if I regret
anything that's always what it is so
don't do that do what you want to do
yeah if you want to travel then [__]
travel but don't do it just because
you're young and single and have no big
commitments it's not you're not
necessarily going to regret that later
in life which is what his implication
was
hmm yeah
yeah true good point all right next one
big fan so I am in the Army and I live
in Barracks Barracks are basically like
college dorms except minor way shittier
so my situation is I have a suite mate
who lives next door that I have to share
a bathroom with and one thing that he
always does is no exaggeration
this noise
like multiple times a day he does it in
the shower when he's on the [__]
and I hear him doing it when he's in his
room I mean
uh I've only had one interaction with
this guy previously where we both
discussed keeping the bathroom clean and
uh it he doesn't do it if I don't clean
it it doesn't get done so let me know
what I should do how I should approach
this up until this point basically all
I've been doing is every time he's in
the bathroom going I hit him back with a
ladder
you know it brings joy to my life
um wow kind of being a dick like that
but yeah let me know I mean that's 100
what you would recommend so you don't
even need to throw up do it so hard that
you throw up
just [__] uh I used to I had a
roommate in college my sophomore year no
you didn't because you didn't make it to
yourself right uh who would Hawk so many
[__] loogies that he would have
kleenex on him at all times and just
spit his loogie into the cleanup oh my
God down where he was oh come on yep
no I don't no you don't oh no you don't
um wow yeah and uh
so I had have had some experience with
disgusting roommates and Suite mates but
I would say the Hawking thing it's
probably like a health reason well ask
him what the [__] is going on what I'm
saying is he's not just doing it for
recreation maybe he's got some situation
where he needs to be doing that
get it figured out the dirty bathroom
thing though no you gotta confront him
about that yeah
you're a [__] tough guy [__] in the
corner of the dirty bathroom anyway he
brings it up be like oh that's what
we're doing [__] on his pillow on his
bed okay well if I get you know
dishonorable discharge yeah but then you
can just say well this guy's always
going would you get through another arm
for my [__] on my roommate's pillow my
sweet mate's pillow why'd you shouldn't
sweep it exactly yeah reinstated
uh give him his medal I mean that sucks
but you can't do anything about this you
can maybe you can maybe but you could be
like Yo dude is everything okay like
with your that's yeah sure that would
work yeah maybe he could go to the you
know whoever the I don't know what a
doctor CEO oh
the CEO yeah Co commanding officer
you're talking about going to a medic
yeah but when when you say CR I think of
that two box on it goes hey Co turn the
[__] lights out okay well you're
talking about Tupac too much you think
I don't know yeah well I do know you do
okay well uh
uh I want to listen to that song again
that's it I don't know that what song is
it it'd say it was on um
are you still down the album oh damn
damn I don't remember that um
posthumously
whatever that word is that's the right
way to say it yeah yeah so I think that
um I think that
that's a also you don't you've only had
one conversation with your sweet man I
guess I don't know how it is weird but
like crazy in the military he said but
um
is that normal that doesn't sound normal
maybe one conversation with someone you
share a living space with no that
doesn't sound that seems weird but he
did say that yeah maybe there's some
like instant animosity between them
maybe he's doing that to piss him off
um yeah that's what I'm saying ask him
about it or start doing your own thing
that is just as loud and disgusting when
he's living in peace in his own in his
own home in his own space right drink a
lot of chocolate milk and just go to the
door and fart
or or drink a lot of chocolate milk and
make yourself throw up when you walk by
him
you know chocolate oh my God I'm so
sorry you know dude I used to drink
chocolate milk so much in high school I
would drink it at lunch no chocolate
milk not Yoo-hoo Yoo-hoo is so good but
you is chocolate yeah but it wasn't
chocolate that's a little watered down
chocolate I'm talking about milk with
chocolate and it was like you know
altadina oh like the mini carton thing
yeah and you drink I would drink it fit
by Fifth period man
dude just straight up and just not
giving a [__] because there's so many
people around you guess what it's not me
yeah yeah well you can fart him in a big
group of people you're always gonna be
okay this is when I fart I go like this
yeah
yo yo yo here
yeah yeah yeah or if you're really
aggressive and the first one to notice
it the smelter Delta thing is you can
blow past that what do you mean like you
know smelt it down it's a lie it's
melted people stand by that and they'll
be like oh you must have done it no if
you bulldozed through that [__] hard
and you're just like oh come on me come
up but you smelt it first you can both
like I'm saying
oh yeah I don't know
maybe it was me you don't smell that
maybe it was me I see you turn it on
turn it around on him yeah yeah
uh I think uh honestly smelta Delta does
a lie I've always thought smell that
thought that was a lie and I I never
subscribed to that and if I smell the
fart first I would say yo that's
somebody not me what do you mean what
does that mean it is a lie
what if someone says it and they're not
lying
the notion of smelt it dealt it he never
smelt it dealt it is a lie you're saying
it's a fallacy it's not a lie
you're lying if you say hey oh dude it
has happened he smelt it he dealt it
that's a lie but it has happened you're
saying it's a lie it's like people say
the Devil is a Lie Rick Ross said that
okay stop that's Rick Ross I didn't say
it was Tupac I've never read a song too
okay all right just bring up rappers
after everything you say you know but
smelt it dealt it is something people
have done before it's cool to say smelta
Delta is a lie oh okay and and I didn't
realize how cool it was until after I
said it a bunch and now I'm like I stand
by that dude okay all right well the
Devil is a way to say that is that it's
a fallacy not a lie but okay do you
think smelt it dealt it saying is more
often true or more often false false
well I know I know what you think that's
a lie uh
I bet it's about half and half hold on
because I bet a lot of people who I bet
a lot of people are like the way to get
out of this is to pretend I'm smelling
it hold on because then that makes me
seem innocent here's why that's where
the whole expression comes from that's
why it's not a lie here's why smelt that
dealt it falls on its face okay
why would you admit that you smell a
fart if it's you first are you were you
[__] born yesterday it's so you can
throw people off it's so that you're you
because because exactly what you said
who would ever do this
no one would ever out themselves out out
a fart that they did themselves so of
course it's not them everyone knows that
so that people are going to be the one
who volunteer not the thought that came
up yeah obviously that's a lie no dude
we just figured it out and you agreed
you're saying half more than half the
people
who go oh someone afford it is that no I
said half and half of the time when
someone is accused of smelted dealt it
is is all right and or and wrong I guess
50 50 yeah oh that's so weird to even
get in the weeds like that about it yes
and I answered him it's weird he asked
that okay
okay do you when you fart I don't fart
okay if you were to okay what percentage
of the time would you be like oh someone
farted
oh that's a good question
um
me 30 percent
put it this way only if it was like
noticeable oh someone farted yeah yeah
that's good you would probably be like
it's me sometimes no no oh so a lot of
big percentage see I go like this
sometimes 70 of the time thirty percent
I go ah come on David So then isn't a
lie
seventy percent of the time I'm truthful
but
if you say something's a lie that means
a hundred percent of the time it's false
you're admitting right now that it's 30
of the time correct that's when you do
it you're
doing it in a way where you're being
obvious that you're doing this like that
it's you you know what I'm saying
probably mostly oh I see what you're
saying he's saying oh David you farted
you know and it's David's not even there
yeah he's like across the room
hello dude you farted the chances are
though that David farted and some you
talk about the capacity in the in recent
memory okay why and I'll tell you why
because he eats everything dude David
Sullivan was over eat a [__] battery
if it looked like a Twinkie you've had
sauce on it yeah exactly dude he came
over last night he came over last night
and he was like he came over from dinner
and I ordered and he ate it
he ate your food I ordered him something
he was like ah it's got cheese on it man
I can't eat that you can't eat cheese
since when
so they talk about smell that Delta but
he has a chi he eats the cheese and then
later on and and then later on I looked
and there was like so much missing out
of the pasta
and then how was he not so fast I don't
know I asked him that the other day what
do you say our friend David Sullivan
who's in all of my Vlogs go look he's
been on this show hasn't he oh yeah he
has been on the show on the live live
show yeah he's so he I don't know how
he's not like
because he's so fat he's he's the kind
of almost he's like an almost fat guy
he's perpetually almost fat like always
almost fat you know what I'm talking
about where he's like about to be fat at
all times but he's never fat
like his button's almost about to go
yeah and he's got like a wide his like
hips are wide on the top of his legs no
not like falling over oh wow it's a dick
yeah uh uh yeah I don't know he's not
he's not that fat he's not that fat yeah
no he's not fat he's almost fat all
right that's what I just said I'm not
even close to it no you're not you have
been in your life but not right now what
that's not true
all right is that the last one what are
we doing that's it
yeah sure okay
hey Matt hey Chris so I have a really
dramatic neighborhood fast forward long
ranty text messages
hey Matt hey Chris so I have a really
dramatic neighbor who's sending these
long ranty very angry text messages
about the noises of our dog Emma here's
Emma
um she says things like and I quote I
think your dog won't stop barking and
the entire building can hear it and it's
very loud she's right at the door doing
it so it's extremely loud not just for
me but for everyone she also said and I
quote I hear you guys clear as day all
day footsteps the dog howling barking I
can hear it all clear as day 24 7. now
we know this neighbor doesn't have any
actual leverage to get us kicked out of
the apartment because we asked him I
can't believe it I'm a barking and we
set up a camera and we can see that Emma
barks for about 10 to 20 minutes each
day after we leave the house for work
and then she stops for the rest of the
day until we return home now we're still
working to reduce this barking because
clearly there's some separation anxiety
there and we found some success already
but this neighbor continues to send us
dramatic text messages asking us to
implement inhumane strategies like shock
collars or spray collars or locking Emma
into a small room at the other end of
the apartment that's not above this
neighbor is there anything we can say to
this neighbor to encourage her to look
Inward and consider her own sensitivity
to neighbor noises
and these are the people that are
running this world and these are people
that are in your government and Joe
Biden is yeah a daughtering fool uh
uh so
so uh just always respond with the same
thing
always responds with the same thing
there's nothing their neighbors can do
there's no recourse they can take
all you should ever do and you should do
this every single time is respond with
LOL
and that and that is it they might they
can respond more it doesn't matter you
don't write it again every time they
have a new complaint you just type back
LOL dude that's it it's so weird it's so
weird that people are just so terrible
man like if the dog like
take it up with the building manager at
that point it's not even I think what
happened is the person probably did take
it up with the building manager but was
told there's nothing we can do we could
and I know but they're gonna keep
pounding the residents who own the dog
because that's their only recourse which
is why
you should just write LOL they're just
obviously super woke people that don't
like Ben Shapiro
no they think he is Ben Shapiro yeah
yeah uh because they've heard him and
his voice is exactly identical to Ben
Shapiro's voice
um
yeah right back LOL
yeah that's a good advice man I mean
that's so dumb that they do that yeah
okay so here's the thing you can't spend
too much time
or energy time and energy thinking about
just true
died in the world
through them through [__] and that's
what that person is and so you gotta
[__] read the text and Kiss It
Goodbye with an LOL and never never
think about it again okay good yeah
that's it you know
all right well that's it that's the show
for today go to chrislea.com to get
tickets I'll be in Minneapolis Milwaukee
Irvine Oxnard and chrisley.com and also
be in Ohio if you got a question uh go
to watch lifeline.com and also you get
the new merch lifeline lifelinemerch.com
and if you have a we want to get a
one-on-one session with Matt go to
mattdelia.com uh and find out how it is
but anyway thanks like And subscribe and
also leave a comment baby pump that I'll
go we love it
thank you
[Music]